شوارع الصين المكتظه تشهد تحولا تاريخيا
بتراجع عدد سكانها لاول مره منذ 60 عاما
حسب بيانات المكتب الوطني للاحصاءات فان
عدد سكان الصين انخفض العامه 2020 بنسبه
0.85 مقارنه بعام 2021 اي بنحوي 850.000
كذلك اظهرت بيانات مكتب الاحصاءات
الحكوميه ان البلاد سجلت العام الماضي
9,56,000 ولاده مقابله اكثر من 10 ملايين
وفاه وبلغ معدل المواليد العام الماضي
6,77 مولودا لكل الف شخص انخفاض هو اقل
معدل لمواليد على الاطلاق ارقام تعكس حجم
المعضله التي وقعت فيها الصين في وقت
تواجه البلاد ازمه ديموغرافيه واقتصاديه
فالمره الاخيره التي سجلت فيها البلاد
انخفاضا في عدد سكانها عام 1960
حينها واجهت الصين اسوا مجاعه في تاريخها
الحديث
[موسيقى]
انخفاض عدد سكان الصين لاول مره منذ عقود
له اسبابه جزء كبير منه يعود لسياسه الطفل
الواحد التي فرضتها الصين بين عامي 1980 و
20015 رغم ان السلطات الصينيه انهت هذه
القيود عام 2016 لكنها لم تنجح في عكس
مسار التدهور الديموغرافي لاسباب حساسه
ابرزها تكاليف التعليم والمعيشه الباهظه
التي ادت الى تجنب عديد من الصينيين ان
جاب اكثر من طفل واحد او حتى انجاب طفل
واحد من الاساس حتى مع الحوافز الماديه
المقدمه لهم
[موسيقى]
لتراجع سكاني تداعياته ايضا فخبر او قالوا
لصحيفه ذاكرتين انهم يتوقعون ان يكون ذلك
بدايه فتره طويله من الانخفاض في اعداد
مواطنيها ما يفتح المجال امام مزيد من
شيخوخه السكان وقله اعداد الشباب الفاعلين
كما ان الانخفاض السريع لاعداد السكان من
شانه ان يعرقل النمو الاقتصادي ويراكم
الضغوط على الخزينه العامه للدوله ويبقى
مستقبلها قاتما ما يجبر الحكومه الصينيه
على تغيير سياساتها الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه والخارجيه
روان حمزه العربيه